say hi hi khloe kardashian and tristan
thompson
are making their first christmas in
boston extra special for their daughter
true
it's such a beautiful thing a source
tells et that chloe is having the best
time with tristan and true
and is really trying to make things feel
homey and celebratory for the holidays
by ordering fun holiday cookies and even
having a christmas tree delivered to
their apartment
in 2019 chloe told et how motherhood has
empowered her i think after you have a
baby you just feel empowered and
just the fact that you're now able to
juggle a child working out and work
i think that's an accomplishment another
source tells et that chloe and tristan
were seen enjoying a date night without
true at the four seasons earlier this
week
this comes after chloe was reportedly
struggling with tristan's move to the
boston celtics
he previously spent nine years with the
cleveland cavaliers
that's just what it is however chloe and
drew were welcomed by the celtics with
open arms
last week chloe posted a gift basket
from the nba team
writing chloe and true welcome to the
team
we wanted to make sure we got you both a
starter pack of gear before the season
starts stay healthy
and go green thank you a source tells et
that chloe's family plans to split their
time between
la and boston but that a permanent move
is up in the air
as chloe and tristan are still working
on rebuilding their
relationship which they've both been
very open about on keeping up with the
kardashians
why now why are you like the man i
dreamed of
currently why couldn't you be that when
we were together like one of my fears is
you're acting like this until you get
what you want and then if you do
you're going to turn into like the old
tristan again no it's been almost a year
like
i don't think anybody like should waste
their time if they're not going to be
serious especially like what i've put
you through like i've grown to a point
where i know what i want in my life and
i know i want you in my life so
obviously we'll always be each other's
life in terms of just because we have
true but i mean
i want more than that
you